hey what's up guys my name is the
churner welcome back to my game engine
series so last time we took a look at
shader library check out that video if
you didn't catch it and today we're
going to be talking about - you're
entering hazel specifically planning a
little bit about what that actually
involves cause it's important to start
off with a plan no matter where you are
in your art design process no matter how
experienced you think you are no matter
how easy it is gonna be doesn't it
doesn't hurt to just make a little plan
even if it's tiny to just actually make
sure that you're not overlooking
anything and with plans on more kind of
more involved tasks let's just say like
something like this is actually quite a
lot of work because we're gonna kind of
plan this out today I've got my little
drawing instrument if you will it's just
a drawing tablet I've got although all
that for this video but it's going to be
kind of taking a look at everything and
planning everything out on a little
piece of paper essentially and as we're
kind of putting together that plan
you'll realize it actually there's a lot
of stuff to this because there is that's
the thing game engines aren't easy to
make renderers aren't easy to make you
think that you might be able to get away
with not doing much work but then you
realize that if you actually want a
really good product it's gonna take more
work before we begin this episode I just
want to thank all of the patrons that
make this series possible patreon
hopefuls that the charity the single
biggest support that I actually have
it's the only reason why I'm able to do
YouTube full-time is because of all of
the people who are pledging to make this
series possible to make all this stuff
possible I'm now working on hazel full
time which means that this stuff is
actually gonna happen like this century
hopefully so I'm kind of just really
focusing on that trying to make as many
videos for you guys as possible so thank
you so much to all the people who make
this possible speaking of which if
you're not interested in 2d
if you'd rather kind of move on to 3d I
have a full 3d render up in hazel
already ready to go like physically
based rendering animation all of that
stuff available in the heddle dev branch
which is available to patrons who do
help support this channel so you can
write interested in there so you can
skip
and take a look at that code and then of
course your support is what makes this
stuff happen
okay so Oh 2d rendering so I did a
little bit of a whiteboard search before
just to kind of gather my thoughts I
think that when when you're planning you
never want to kind of do all of your
planning in one day or do all of your
planning kind of just in this moment the
reason is that the human brain works in
a very fascinating and interesting way
in the sense that time is important for
very many things time is so important if
you don't let anything in your brain
actually sit there for a while and you
just jump to conclusions it's I mean I'm
it's just seriously gonna cause you so
much havoc right if you just like you
want to buy a car you want to buy a
house or something
and you just instantly impulse buy
something it's probably not gonna be the
right decision same with this right if
you feel learning something new if
you're trying to learn a musical
interests instrument if you're trying to
learn how to do a trick on your
skateboard I don't know if you're trying
to learn something new and you try it if
you're learning how to drive a manual
car for example if you just try and do
that all in one setting it's gonna be
very difficult but if you just take a
break and you come back the next day
you'll be like well let's do this isn't
as hard as it was yesterday
the reason is that your brain has kind
of just taken time to process things and
I think that's super important with
planning if I just sit down and all in
one session I just like to sit down with
a piece of paper write right out this is
gonna be much beauty renderer this is
how I'm gonna link everything together
not gonna be a good idea it's gonna be
way better if over the course of a week
for example I kind of just write a few
things in in the first day I'll write
everything I think is required and then
I'll kind of walk past that whiteboard
or something the next day and I'll be
like hang on a minute how did I forget
this how did I forget that so many
things to overlook I put out a video a
few days ago about basically it was like
a day in the life kind of videos what
kind of a hazel 2d development blog or a
vlog check out that video if you haven't
already because in that in that video I
actually talked a lot about kind of
I'm how I'm approaching this and I
actually show off what I've kind of
achieved at the end of the day which is
basically a 2d renderer so I'm kind of
following along with that in my own time
and just building up this 3d render and
along the way I'm kind of figuring out
how to actually break this into episodes
for you guys because of course 2d did
win the poll and we're moving on with a
2d renderer for hazel anyway um without
further ado let's just take a look at
Eddie I want to start by looking at some
code that is basically our code right
now because that's the thing we kind of
have a 2d renderer or a lot of you might
think we kind of have a 2d renderer why
well we can render 2d sprites we can
have quads with textures we've done that
already we have the Cherno logo we have
like a checkerboard background we have
blending working we can clearly like
sample from textures we can clearly load
textures we can clearly render squares
we did like the whole grid before you
know we have a grid of squares how is
that going to be different than an
actual 2d renderer why is what we're
doing here so much more complicated well
all will be revealed in this video
because there's so much that goes into
this anyway let's just take a look at
what we have right now and how what
we're gonna be designing and creating is
gonna be very different and also we'll
take a look a little bit as to how the
API for this new renderer will actually
work okay so this is the current state
of the hazel repository if we take a
look at the actual running program
well that's compiling I just want to
kind of quickly make a little up there
just to say that um we have a logo now
this is a little logo that I've made and
also after the readme in the repository
that actually kind of states both our
plan and kind of features that we're
interested in and what the plan is just
in general as well as how to actually
get hazel because a lot of people were
having issues actually downloading and
compiling hazel properly so there's a
little bit of information about that as
well as a logo so hopefully you guys
like the logo didn't take me hint took
me a couple of hours but I think it's
really nice I like to keep things simple
so yeah the amount of time for the stuff
gets printed on hoodies and t-shirts of
course so back to actual hazel we have
this right now this is what it is and we
can move
using our case we're entering a whole
grid and we are in fact rendering
textures as well so this is basically
this is D these are the components to a
basic 2d renderer there's no doubt about
that
you could make a game with this easily
right you can just resize these and make
them like blocks and have a little
character which you could even make like
a texture out of you don't even have to
use flat colors you could do whatever
you want we have a nice shader system
you could even just modify the shaders
and make something even cooler you have
what you need and obviously we have like
the event system in hazel and just in
general we have input events you could
easily basically make a complete game
with what we have right now maybe - the
audio that's probably the biggest thing
that's missing everything else would
probably not be too difficult to add so
why is what we're designing like why is
that going to be different well let's
take a look at how it's gonna be
different first of all the way that we
do everything right now is we submit it
to the renderer now this is fine if we
look at our actual renderer submission
what we do is we begin a scene which
sets our view matrix a view projection
matrix and then we submit data to it
which right now kind of sets the
transform and says the view projection
as well from what we submitted earlier
it finds the shader binds the vertex
array and then actually draws that
vertex array and that's what we have
right now for our render now this is
fine but this is very 3d esque right
this is what you would do in a 3d
renderer because you know submitting
like a shader submitting a vertex array
you know setting up a new projection
matrix doing that kind of stuff is
setting a transform that's not
traditionally stuff you would do in a 2d
renderer because there's just no need to
that the huge benefit I guess or it's
really like a difference as well but
it's a benefit in a lot of ways with 2d
rendering specifically is that you don't
have to worry about 3d models with
masses of vertices which could be very
different from each other you don't have
to worry about different shaders or
materials and these were material
properties instead everything is
essentially a quad everything's a
rectangle like yes you could rent a line
circles all that different geometry but
usually all you render is a quad I mean
even if you want a circle a lot of times
it's actually just easier to render a
square and then have a texture which is
your circle and then you can of course
have a have some alpha like transparency
in that texture so that it makes like a
circle shape and just discard the pixels
that don't need to get rented that a lot
of that that's just a better way of
rendering like there's very few cases in
which I would actually be like hey I
want to render a circle using like a
triangle fan because that's just that's
too much geometry like to get a perfect
circle in a 2d renderer that's like not
like jagged edges
you know you need so many vertices why
just render a texture it's so much
easier and you can have that as smooth
as you want really because you're
dealing with per pixel basis which is
really what to tear n during is about so
this set up in general not great because
we we have all this extra stuff here
like materials and stuff in the future
that will come to a 3d renderer stuff
that we don't actually need for a two
year and release channel let's jump back
and take a look at some more things so
the biggest the biggest thing here is
that we just have one way of submitting
render calls and that is to this kind of
render submit now the thing is this is
intended for 3d rendering so we go a
little bit of a different problem how do
we discern between what is 3d and the
three and the 3d API and then what is
kind of 2d and our end or a 2d API well
there's a few ways we could do this you
might be tempted and let's just go back
to renderer begin scene you might be
tempted to just just basically say that
well okay why don't you begin a 2d scene
you know we'll just say begin scene to e
you can pass in an orthographic camera
maybe you have an actual scene object
that defines the scene a little bit in
more detail than just the camera for
example you could have anything you want
want to do that well you could do that
but then we have a problem because what
if we want to draw a quad we could just
do draw quad right but hold on a minute
is this quad being drawn in 3d land or
2d land
okay well let's maybe look at the scene
that was begun maybe we should have a
restriction where you
to begin either an a scene or a scene to
D if you begin a scene to you you have
to end the scene to D before you can
begin a seam 3d for example which is
just a regular scene you could have that
so contextually we know that a 2d scene
has begun maybe that's a 2 e quad well
sure but what about if we want to draw a
quad in 3d if does it really look the
same and then it just depends if a 2d
scene has begun or a 3d scene has begun
that seems a little bit like ridiculous
and it's gonna just it's gonna cause
problems well okay fine what if a quad
is 2d and then a rectangle is 3d do we
really want to say P either do we really
want to be insane and then draw rect is
to draw a 3d rectangle and draw quarters
to draw a 2d one or vice versa
that's gonna create so much confusion
why have something like that and so
because of that it kind of becomes
apparent pretty quickly that we don't
want to have a begin same 2d we actually
want to have a physically like different
renderer and so because of that we are
introducing the renderer to D now it
would call this render a 3d render or 2d
I don't think that's required I think
that hazel primarily is going to be a 3d
engine anyway it's going to be capable
of 2d of course but I think that when
you think of the hazel renderer you're
thinking of a 3d render not a 2d
renderer so because of that we're gonna
leave renderer as is but then we're
gonna make a renderer 2d specifically
for 2d things and don't get me wrong
this is not something like I'm making a
3d game in hazel so I don't care about
render a 2d yes you do because what
about any kind of 2d graphics what about
UI what about you know main menus what
about you know anything really that is
that has to be rendered as an actual 2d
kind of projection you have so many
things in a 3d game that are still
rendered as tui so this still this is
very important you'll definitely have
this in your 3d game which is why it's
important to create this because not
only do I want hazel to be able to
create 2d and 3d games but even if
you're just doing 3d you still need this
so then once we have our renderer 2d we
can then begin a scene and this will
probably take in like an author
the camera and then you know maybe it'll
take in a scene if we have like a scene
2d kind of object maybe that and there's
Litton that might just contain data that
is required by a 2d scene and then from
there of course we'll you will do render
a 2d drop pod and then that will
actually create and draw a quad on the
screen in a 2d context of course in
regards to that camera or that scene or
whatever it's being used now I don't
want to I don't want to really confuse
you guys too much so we'll still just
pretend that we have a camera here
well we won't worry about scene objects
anytime soon see that's kind of what the
API begins to look like now from here
you might think about well what else you
do what what else do you want to draw do
you want to draw a circle what about if
you want to you know draw a circle
that's kind of not filled in well maybe
draw a circle versus feel circle we
might have something like a filled
circle that will actually result in us
in like a circle that's been filled with
a particular color
what about lines like drawing lines is
kind of useful rectangles stuff like
that as I mentioned earlier though for
things like circles you know if you're
making a game and you kind of have you
kind of just have your let's just say
you you know it's like a platformer game
and you have this kind of terrain here
you have like a bunch of like platforms
around here and you have your character
which we'll say is a circle as I
mentioned you'll probably still draw
that as an actual square as a rectangle
as a quad and then this stuff will just
be kind of transparent in your texture
and you apply a texture to it which will
contain like essentially a circle is
just surrounded by pixels with
absolutely no values right so for
example a pixel with the Alpha set to
zero which means that it's transparent
and that's kind of how you'll draw your
main character not to mention that
you'll probably want to maybe have an
actual character you know not just a
circle but in this example if we just
kind of deal with the game it's really
simple and has no real graphics that is
how we would probably achieve something
like this so we end up with this API
that really if we dumb this down all we
kind of need is to have this kind of
renderer 2d you know begin scene which
is kind of our card for actually
starting a scene with it
kill a camera and then we can have our
submission so for example render a 2d
and then draw quad and then that is
pretty much all we kind of need for the
time being now this quad what kind of
parameters do we give it well we need to
give things like the position we need to
give things like this size what about
the color or maybe instead of the color
it's got a texture stuff like that needs
to actually go into draw quad and that's
pretty much all that we need of course
and this is kind of in the traditional
sense thinking that like this is not
like some kind of special effect we're
drawing this is just you know something
we are just drawing some kind of
primitive on the screen which has like a
texture applied to it or a color applied
to it and that's kind of as simple as
that really
gets so in other words we'd be rendering
with just our standard kind of 2d shader
now we get to the problem here and the
problem isn't really it's not really a
problem it might not be a problem
depending on what you are building
exactly but basically what we might want
to have is a lot of 2d images a lot of
2d quads on the screen at one time so
how do we do that well we do that by a
process called batching now I'm not
talking about like you know a visual
effects system or a particle system that
has millions of particles and we have to
like you know compute all that stuff on
the GPU because that's the only way it's
possible to remember that many actual
primitives on the screen now talking
about that I'm just talking about maybe
you have like a maybe you're you're kind
of making a role-playing game you know
and you have like this huge kind of tile
map and you want to zoom out all the way
and you want to be able to see all these
tiles at once maybe you see thousands
upon thousands of tiles at once what if
you have a game well that's made up of
that many tiles well do you know how are
you gonna render all of them at once
well if we have 10,000 tiles that we
want on the screen at one time because
we really like zoomed out or just for
whatever reason we have 10,000 2d quads
that we want to draw at once if we try
and do that using the method that we're
doing right now which is kind of
submitting it as like a draw call that's
not gonna work like on a great computer
that's not really
it's gonna give you a terrible frame
where it's gonna be very slow
inefficient because what we actually
want to do is kind of batch all of those
together into one piece of geometry so
what happens is when you submit a card
when you submit it for when you've begun
a scene you set a camera and you've
started kind of being like to record
record record you call render a 2d draw
cord 10,000 times what actually needs to
happen is those that kind of all of the
all of the properties all the attributes
that make that quad that quad so its
position in size its texture its color
all of that stuff that basically all
that data goes in as vertex data into a
big vertex buffer a dynamic vertex
buffer that you're updating every frame
so every time this happens not every
time you draw a quad but every time you
beat every frame you're updating that
vertex buffer with the information that
it that it needs and that way you know
instead of you know ten thousand quads
being ten thousand rock walls ten
thousand quads are going to be one girl
called potential it could be it depends
how you kind of change it and in fact
that video that I mentioned that kind of
hazel to the development log there the
first one that actually goes into more
detail about this stuff I will probably
make a complete tutorial about how to
just a batch render in OpenGL I was like
a standalone OpenGL video I think not in
hazel just for those of you who are
interested in it in like kind of a more
generic context but basically that's the
idea so to batch together those things
we need to basically create a batch
renderer which is what we will do for
this kind of renderer to me that's what
it will be it will just be about
renderer so our goal is going to be to
kind of handle this render batching I'll
call this like I'll just say batch
renderer and what will list will kind of
start listing all of our kind of
features I guess that would that we want
in our kind of 2d system and what this
kind of 2d project and hazel will
actually begin to involve so it is that
renderer let's set some goals here so I
want to draw maybe let's just say
100,000 sprites so I said 10,000 before
that's not that impressive I think a
hundred thousand for a stress test
should be able to happen
like 60fps and I want this with textures
now not really sure what that's gonna
look like if you guys saw that
hazel 2d dev vlog that I put up you
would you would say that I was actually
able to render like half a million I
think at that framerate but I think that
this this would this is certainly going
to be a bit a little bit of a difficult
goal especially on hardware that isn't
particularly powerful but on my computer
in my office which is quite powerful I
definitely want to be able to do a
hundred K with textures I think that
that should not be a problem
now when you start involving textures
into a bat renderer you quickly discover
that if you have something like a
role-playing game let's just say with
the entire it's a 2d kind of top-down
role-playing game and you have this
incredibly large world that's a tile map
right you start to think about all the
different textures that are involved
here you know you could have certain
areas that are basically like water
tiles and then you might have like grass
you might have dirt you might have these
houses in place you might have a whole
bunch of stuff in your 2d world here
that basically is gonna be a whole bunch
of textures now it's probably rare to
have more than like I don't know you
know we have a hundred thousand sprites
and we might have ten thousand textures
like that's that's a little bit
ridiculous don't think that will
actually happen what will actually
happen is you might have my denial let's
just say like a hundred to two hundred
textures that you want to render out
once anything beyond that would be a
little bit crazy now that's not too bad
because if we look at like a modern GPU
with let's just say thirty-two each
texture slots let's take away like eight
for other uses and we'll say that we
have 24 texture slots now eight is being
very like generous to take away eight
like that's you probably will have the
full 32 to use I couldn't like that
maybe you'll have 30 like eight is a lot
even with that if you have 100 of these
that means that you have to flush a
render of five times right which means
that if you are rendering a hundred
thousand sprites with you know a hundred
different textures that still only will
require five drop
so in other words you'll probably be
fine however you know if you factor in
other things that we might have to do
like you know text rendering which we'll
talk about in a minute
it's basically safe to say that once we
start introducing textures to a batch
renderer we probably want to have some
kind of sprite sheet or a texture Atlas
system so what a texture atlas is is
basically kind of like how we bash
together geometry into one vertex buffer
this is basically us patching together
textures into one texture so a whole
bunch of textures you know we can put
into like a single texture basically and
that will be a lot more efficient
because then we can just read part of
that texture when we need to render a
particular piece of geometry or when
we're sampling it for it like for a
pixel in on our screen we can just
sample from a sub region of that texture
to get the texture that we actually want
now obviously if your textures a huge
like 4k textures you're probably not
gonna get away with having a texture
atlas but if you're making like a a low
resolution retro style game you could
you know and your sprites are like you
know let's just say 32 by 32 pixels
which is actually quite large you could
definitely get away with just simply
having all of your sprites probably in a
single kind of section Atlas that's not
too difficult to pull off so because of
that you could still render a hundred or
200 textures or whatever with just a
single draw I don't actually know how
much will fit in like you know if you
have if each texture is 32 by 32 you
know you probably will be able to easily
fit a lot of textures into about 32 by
32
sorry into the you know if you have like
a 4k let's just say you have a 4k um
sprite sheet you know a lot of 32 by 32
textures are gonna fit into this area so
you will be able to just store
everything in there so we all need like
a texture other system that's something
else that this renderer will have to
support so bat renderer lots of sprites
with vertex colors and textures texture
Atlas support let's see what else do we
have once we talk about texture atlases
and in general 2d rendering we probably
want and
so basically what this means is that I
want to have animated sprites I want my
character to actually move his legs when
he moves I want water to actually move
right we need some kind of animation how
do we pull that off well the simplest
way is probably just to harvest another
spreadsheet that you take in and this
spreadsheet is going to basically be
divided let's just say we're going with
32 by 32 every frame is going to be a
separate texture in that sprite sheet
and all we do is when it's time to
render we just have that texture ready
to go that's like our player kind of
sheet now play a sprite sheet up play a
texture Atlas we have that ready to go
we upload that should we just bind that
texture on our GPU and then we can
basically select which frame it's time
to render and that's it but all the
frames are in one texture easily done
now what if you have you know we're
assuming this is a low res but why 2d
rendering doesn't have to be low
resolution what if that player is quite
big what if our player textures are 2k
or 1000 pixels by a thousand pixels if
it's 1024 how are we going to do that
well you know you can't really have all
of that in a sprite sheet so instead
what we'll probably need is some kind of
custom format that basically encodes
frames together kind of like what like a
video codec would do where you kind of
have your key frame and then the next
frame is basically a bunch of deltas so
all the pixels that have changed that's
what you record and then when it's time
to actually decide what frame number one
looks like so this is frame 0 what frame
number 1 looks like you basically have
to go to your nearest key frame that
it's back in time so frame 0 will say
and then apply this Delta through that
frame and that's how you figure out what
this actual what this actual frame will
look like so this requires quite a lot
of work and you might want to compress
that data and do all of that with it
very similar to a video codec I actually
wrote a system like this for EA a few
years ago something like that would
probably be required right and you can
of course an applied that to 32 by 32
pixels sprites so in that sense instead
of ending up with one texture with one
sprite sheet you basically just when
it's time to render you look up what
frame you're
- you decode those pixels and then you
update that texture that is your player
texture with that actual frame data so
that is also that might be required
that's another thing that you have to
consider for a 2d renderer I'm running
out of space here let's move over here
so next step we've got animation we can
render stuff it's looking pretty good
but what about UI I mentioned that UI is
really really important is a really
important component of 2d rendering
right and in fact that's even that's
probably where you'll see 2d rendering
in 3d games the most so what about UI
well for that we basically need a layout
system now a layout system has to be
quiet is actually quite complex because
if you look at a screen you might have
all these different UI elements on the
screen like for example we might have
like player's high score up here we
might have like you know invent the
inventory that the player is actually
carrying over here let's just say you
know we might have different inventory
screens to pop up we might have like a
little pause menu that pops up this
pause menu has to be centered vertically
and horizontally what about this what
happens when we resize the window if we
make it smaller or larger this has to be
kind of I guess anchored to the top and
the right edges of our actual screen but
then I also want to maintain a certain
padding distance you know what if we
want to render text but we want it to be
right aligned or we want it to be Center
aligned how do we do all of these things
well we need a good layout system what
if I gave is not resizable but we want
it we want to support a variety of
different resolutions you know what if
someone's rendering 4k does 16:9 is like
a 4:3 monitor for example what if this
is what if this has my boss support and
we're on a phone we're you know our
resolution might be something like 9 18
it might be in portrait mode you know we
might have 9 to 19 you know the whole
bunch of different phones out there
right now and we might have to support
all of this stuff for different kind of
layouts for this stuff another great
example is an ultra-wide monitor you
know we might be like twenty one to nine
we need to still be able
the game at that resolution and we want
to have our high score anchored to the
right and our menu appear in the center
and all of that stuff speaking of which
you know what about text rendering how
do we render the word pause on the
screen well we need to somehow load a
font using probably something like
freetype we need to be able to put all
the characters that get used as they get
used dynamically into a spreadsheet so
that we can kind of figure out what the
best way to actually pack those
rectangles is as well because different
letters of course take different shapes
and we want to basically instead of just
packing them kind of one by one we want
to optimally kind of try and save on
space save on texture space because
there might be potentially a lot of
stuff that we render so we need some
kind of rectangle packing algorithm as
well end up with a lot of stuff here and
in fact this stuff having worked on a
mobile engine for ei before this is
probably the the largest system besides
like the actual like 3d renderer to be
honest this is huge not to mention
having dedicated tools dedicated tools
for the artist to actually be able to
create these layouts basically having
something like After Effects that we
actually made so that you can you know
animate things using keyframes and have
all of these layouts and main menus you
know all of that stuff so that artists
can actually create what they need to
create this is a huge system and it's
definitely necessary to have at least
two to a certain extent in the hizzle 2d
renderer okay what's next we've got a
pretty good-looking scene but we can
probably do better what about post
effects now post effects and all that
kind of stuff you might think is more of
like a 3d thing and I mean it is to an
extent but like there's no reason to not
have that stuff in 2d especially we're
going for good-looking 2d graphics right
so let's just say we have an explosion
there's no reason for that explosion to
not be so bright that it actually
creates balloon and in fact speaking of
explosions we probably also want to have
some kind of particle system and again
this doesn't necessarily have to exist
for 3d what about fatuity what if we
were to have a 2d explosion you know we
could encode it as a video I guess but
it'd be cool to have it kind of dynamic
and randomized at actual runtime so that
requires some kind of visual
or like a particle system to have that
bloom we also need to think about HDR so
that we have a proper HDR pipeline and
then we can add bloom using post effects
other post effects you know what if we
have our pause menu being brought up
like this or an inventory screen
wouldn't it be nice to just kind of blur
the background maybe that would look
beautiful right having the rest of our
game world just kind of be blurred and
out of focus so that people can actually
focus on the pause menu or stuff that we
want to bring to their attention that
also requires post effects what about
color grading we could of course just
kind of have some kind of color standard
that we apply to all of our textures
because this is 2d rendering we don't
need to worry about like dynamic
lighting or things like that speaking of
which there might be another thing but
let's people enough now so we could
enforce that upon actual texture
creation but wouldn't it be nice to just
kind of do that stuff actually in the
engine so in other words you could have
like color correction curves you know to
add contrast or you know look-up tables
to a certain looks and change the way
the colors work if you want to have like
a blue kind of Tim to everything maybe
because it's kind of like a cold
environment versus something warm that
might be indoors then so much stuff
color grading is definitely a must you
know you might say blue maybe not
blurring maybe not but like color
correction and color grading that kind
of stuff is super important I think to
have if you're going for anything that
you think is gonna look good now this
kind of stuff that's that this is just
the renderer you know what about what we
need to make an actual 2-d game well the
first thing I think of when I think of
like an actual game is of course I think
of the interaction for a game so when we
think of interaction what do we think of
now I I personally and it's probably
isn't like the first thing that comes to
everyone's heads but I immediately start
thinking of scripting because scripting
is a way now we don't need scripting
because you could just use C++ did all
this you know something like like an
entity component system and like you
know components and stuff is probably
the first thing that a lot of people
think about when they think of
interaction actually how to make a game
and what you need in a game engine for
that but I kind of think of scripting
you know whether that be kind of like a
scripting language you know having
something like Aloha
what about visual scripting something
like blueprints in unreal or in
frostbite is called schematics how do we
have something like that because that is
that is kind of the biggest component to
how people will actually make games with
hazeled they'll write scripts that do
certain things what about an entity
component system you know or something
basically called CGR which is composable
game objects basically game objects that
are composable so they're composable of
components they could they're composed
from components rather than just being
composed by inheritance for example that
kind of stuff you know so that we can
have like our player entity essentially
and then the player entity will have
certain components like a transform
component so they exist somewhere in the
world maybe like a 2d renderer
kind of component so that we can
actually render it somewhere what about
script attached to it for things like
interaction and so that we're gonna hook
in things like input you know we need
all of this stuff to actually make this
happen and you can see that this becomes
quite a lot of work so I don't really
want to overwhelm you guys and you can
see how dark is actually gotten outside
this is this is how much stuff there is
to do for 2d rendering so this is gonna
be something that is really gonna take a
while and I'm actually quite happy that
we've decided to go with 2d rendering I
ran a poll for those of you who don't
know and 51% butter for 2d rendering
over three rendering for us to kind of
do first in the hazel engine I'm really
happy we're doing this and the reason is
that this is a lot of work if we kind of
were to go with Freddy
unfortunately what would have happened
is three is even more work 3d is
something that would really just
continue on pretty much forever and the
sad thing is that unless we decided to
that's it I'm taking a break from 3d
this stuff would never get done ever but
even though this might look daunting and
even though at the end of this I want to
basically be able to make games and
hazel Tetris you know space invaders
asteroids you know all those classic
arcade games as well as like a
role-playing game or something a little
bit new like platformers with really
nice graphics and like post-processing
effects
looks really nice I want to have that
stuff done by the end of this and that's
really cool because this is actually
achievable it might take like a year I
don't know I haven't split this up into
episodes yet it's gonna be a long
journey but it's gonna be really cool
and it's gonna teach you guys a lot and
sort of that's the reason why it's great
that we're doing this stuff now because
I feel like if we didn't do this stuff
now we would never get around to it with
our complex 3d years and how long that
would take now I know that this stuff is
not going to be interesting for everyone
um and it kind of sucks but that's kind
of the nature of this series this is the
game engine series we're building a game
engine yes it's going to be a 3d game
engine but it's also going to support 2d
rendering of course and because of that
it really is hard to tailor my content
to everyone but there is still hope for
no matter what you're interested in
because we have this kind of game engine
series that's what's gonna happen with
all this stuff that's going to be 2d
rendering right now in hazel and this is
where we're actually going to be
breaking the stuff down I'm gonna be
teaching it not just writing the code
and this is kind of I guess the learning
process but also just like that vlog I
made I will still continue to make hazel
2d logs right so like development vlogs
essentially and these as a huge circle
and those are going to be kind of more
of like an overview of as I add all
these things because I'm gonna do this
stuff personally in my own private code
first so that I know of course what to
write in the game engine series and what
stuff to actually teach so that's gonna
be visible to you guys in the form of
hopefully nice entertaining vlogs and
I'll cover I'll just show off cool stuff
basically it'll be like a showcase so
for those of you who are interested in
this stuff but you don't want to wait
like you know week to week like a whole
year for all of this stuff to actually
be taught and implemented you can get
the kind of overview and see where this
is going in these kind of things and
that will kind of be primarily 2d but
then I'll also have all of the hazel 3d
kind of vlogs and I did one of them a
while ago basically we had
I was like fixing animation or something
and I'll link that video in the top
right corner as well for those of you
interested who hasn't seen it but this
is gonna be us developing 3d stuff I'm
really passionate about 3d all right I'm
not gonna if you think that I'm gonna
give this up and I'm just for the next
year or whatever I'm just gonna focus on
to to eat my personal life that's not
happening because I literally got into
programming the reason I started
learning code is because I wanted to
render 3d stuff myself I was always kind
of an artist I love creating things but
instead of kind of using you know
programs like 3d max Maya blender that
kind of stuff I wanted to render stuff
by myself that's why I got into
programming in the first place
I really want to build a beautiful 3d
scene I'm gonna do that I'm gonna write
I'm gonna make hazel 3d look absolutely
amazing I mean it's already a pretty
functional pretty renderer but I'm gonna
just add so much more to that probably
expand the api's that is the thoughts to
support like Vulcan directx12 stuff like
that specifically because I want to do
ray tracing not because you know
real-time right ray tracing using like
you know direct X ray tracing and that
kind of stuff because just because I
want to push that graphic fidelity if it
wasn't for that I probably would have
sticked opengl because you can still
kind of do it or pretty much everything
you need to do in OpenGL it may be a
little bit slower but anyway the point
is I want to push that I'm gonna make a
whole 3d scene and I'm gonna still kind
of show you guys that stuff in the form
of these kind of dev logs of hazel 3d
this content is gonna be available for
everyone so no matter no matter what
you're kind of interested in
they'll be stuff for you and in fact I
really want to bring back that OpenGL
series as well and actually start
showing you guys how to implement like
you know how to open 3d models for
example and render 3d models on the
screen in OpenGL in basically one video
from start to finish maybe starting with
like a based library but essentially
stuff like that so there will be 3d
actual education content on this channel
as well not to mention the hazel 3d
stuff and all that source code is always
gonna be available for patrons at any
time so it will be available to you guys
don't worry even though we're picking 2d
here and we're going to focus on the
hardcore like in depth 2d education as
far as like the education side of this
goes and teaching you how to do
everything and why I'm doing it this way
and why it works and how
works all that stuff is going to be
focused on tui they're still gonna be
plenty of content for both 2d and 3d in
the form of like a different format
essentially on this channel so anyway
that's the plan that's where we're
heading hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you did please hit that like button
please help support me and everything
I'm doing by going a patron of home for
Saturday sure no huge thank you everyone
who makes this stuff possible I'm really
excited for the future I'm really
excited for what we're gonna make here
yeah I'll see you guys in the next video
goodbye
[Music]